[Musique]
voici maintenant une nouvelle expérience
de la ratp sur la ligne 7 porte de la
villette mairie d'ivry il s'agit de
l'arrêt des trains dans les stations est
précisément de la limitation de leur
stationnement en vue de réduire à une
minute 45 secondes
l'intervalle entre deux trains aux
heures d'affluence pour cela la ratp
souhaite ne plus voir les rassemblements
désordonnés sur l'épée il faut gagner
des secondes pour augmenter le nombre de
trains en service la bousculade pour
pénétrer dans une seule voiture alors
que d'autres sont aussi à votre
disposition retards dans le trafic
mais depuis dimanche
une hôtesse vous dit
ce qu'il est plus raisonnable de faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc ce qui devrait selon la ratp
vous faire gagner du temps mais
attention l'opération à l'epu de demande
une certaine discipline
suivez bien
[Musique]
entrée du facile les voyageurs sont
mieux répartis sur le quai la montée de
ces derniers est beaucoup plus rapide
mais stop on entre pure ce signal et oui
messieurs vous resterez sur le quai même
s'il ya une petite place pour vous
le signal de départ sera donné dans un
temps déterminé en fonction du trafic
résultats attendus capacité de transport
augmenté de plus de 10% et dans une
oeuvre en service 60 trains au lieu de
cinq ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]